are you voice actors are you voice
performers what's like the what's the
word are we what's your word I'm sorry
wrong wouldn't offend you laughter um
nice a voice actor somebody ask me what
I do but I don't know I feel like all
that's changing now with so much motion
capture I don't know where that fits
into it right arguing is is motion
capture becoming more and more part of
every gig yeah definitely yeah we say
voice actors I think just so that we can
cut down on the conversation time you
say actors people like what have I seen
you in your like right how do you yeah
you'll say what animated shows you been
in you'll save me when I interact your
projects you've been in but motion
capture showing up and pretty much all
of the Triple A titles of yeah
definitely that's uh problematic for you
guys at all not really change the work
at all cuz it definitely changes the
work yeah um it just it creates more
time in the development process with us
like when we did second son it was
really one of the first times that we
were involved so early on in the game
you know as a voice actor so much of the
game is made and then we come in and
we're the cherry on top of all of the
substance that's been worked on for
months yeah with with motion capture you
come in so early because it takes so
long to get all the input and everything
um we get to really have more say and
who the characters become and a little
more influence in the story and
everything like that which is a more
satisfying interest as performers to be
sure I mean the creative process is such
a you know such a precious thing you get
to go in and speak with the writing team
and they're asking your input and maybe
they're looking for some inspiration
here they're maybe they use it maybe
they don't but you just feel like you're
more invested it means more to you and
you really get to know the studio's all
the all the people that make it work and
you know when you're in a recording
booth very rarely do you get to meet all
of the animators and everything behind
it and um it's so nice to get to go to
the studio and see see everything that
goes into and there's so much more than
you would ever expect yeah it's all it's
always a great experience because you're
we are as excited to see the QA
department the animators the writers and
lighting specialists all those people
and then they are equally excited to
meet the people that they've been
staring at for
you know six months probably cursing it
sometimes well their families are at
home wondering where they are so a green
got stuck on my chair and I was like
totally awkwardly like looking at your
tank under the chair to send this ring
Matt and Marissa gave me actually you
just trapped me first to the ten WOD
negative five to Dexter and what was the
first ya wrong show I was earlier
throwing event and what was the how do
you get into diamond that you probably
answer this question about a thousand
one times but like how is it presumably
now once you're in here you're finding
gigs a lot easier because you're making
those connections and you have this like
palliative work that you've been working
on have but it must be quite difficult
to actually break in the first place the
very first gig you get yeah incredibly
hard um but everybody finds it in a
different way you know when when we both
started we were in Texas and Funimation
was the very first place we ever worked
which was um you know anime and my first
gig was Dragon Ball Z hmm um and I only
found it I only got the audition because
I was in a play and somebody there saw
me and you know they recommended me for
the show and so I got to go in and lodge
for Dragon Ball Z but you can't just
call up a studio you can't just like see
what's happening so I it's so hard just
to hear the auditions are coming up and
then be able to get your foot in the
door there right yeah I mean your entire
life has been basically taken that way
because of a chance encounter
essentially yeah it was it one play that
I did yeah created this entire world of
acting for me that I never even realized
exists yet did you have any visibility
onyl to yourself what was it something
you always wanted to do or like how does
it come about
I didn't plan for it at all I you know I
went to college to study theater and
performance arts and that was that was
pretty much it I didn't know if that was
going to be film or TV right you know
those are like the big dreams but I was
still in Fort Worth Texas at the time
and when Funimation came along I was a
fan of dragon pool for years before I
even realized that she was in the show
so when I knew that she was a character
I was like I I don't that character
sounds like that doesn't sound anything
like Lori how that's impossible and you
listen again and instantly that
curiosity of like how Travis get drunks
is so sixty you wanna marry
what are you doing literally loading the
cannon right now I be fired for years
and years yeah and I'm after realizing
that this show that I was such a fan of
who's done so close I founded her and
pretty much everybody else that I knew
that worked there for months and years
and you know finally got an audition
didn't blow it didn't suck hmm and and
it just kind of went out from there but
and never had any intention of like
being a video game voice actor or
animation voice actor and it was only
after you first consider their offer
after I first considered like all these
animes are things that we can work in
you know being such a cartoon fan
growing up loving Thundercats loving
Silverhawks loving Voltron I was like
you know to me his kids those were just
those characters lived by themselves
they weren't real people all right ways
to by adults I didn't want to know
anything about them I was like wow how's
that possibility home it's crazy
yeah I didn't even know like I still
even in Dallas for the eight years that
I was a voice actor I was doing a lot of
other on camera and I thought that's
still the direction I was gonna go voice
acting was this fun thing I got to do on
the side of yeah but it still didn't pay
that much and it was just fun to do and
and then after I moved out to California
the whole world opened up because
there's just so much more you know
available out here then there was back
in Texas and that's when I realized this
this side of things can actually be a
career that's crazy and awesome and
freeing now the weird thing about the
acting business which I'm sure has been
said before many times there's no like
set path there's no ladder to climb
you know people asked like can I go get
voice acting training somewhere yeah
yeah sure and you know does it help if I
do theater or if I go take workshops
yeah it does you know and nothing's ever
yes or no it's just sometimes it's a
complete accident sometimes it's kismet
sometimes people come at it from
stand-up some people come from on-camera
work some people come from a theater
production
yeah Blair Athletes some people are
comedians some people I mean it just you
know it's just a different number of
things and we just normally tell people
like if it's something that you really
want to do when you think you have a
talent in it then just pursue it
relentlessly and whatever that will
happen will happen as a lifestyle is it
something I mean you guys have a couple
as well and so
is it is it less demanding in some ways
than on-camera work because it's a bit
more like like the project sugar the one
because I I don't know anyone who works
as an act I have friends who work in
lighting and stuff in high when the days
seem to drag on forever so you're
constantly on call for like yeah yes
that that doesn't happen in voice actor
which is in voice acting which is really
nice you usually have a set schedule
right but there's a trade-off yeah yeah
yeah whereas like our days might be
shorter the use of your immediate
visceral imagination is far higher
because if you're in motion capture
you're in a blank room with no set
certainly no effects no makeup no
lighting it is just your old school
theater imagination and hopefully that's
a great like matching up with what the
performer in your space is also
imagining here this block of styrofoam
is now your gun yeah you know usually
your weapons are actually label click
weapons but everything else is just a
you know a prop that doesn't this is it
hat it's now a hat and you're it's your
hat yeah you quickly see who has the
ability to really like you know conform
and warp their imaginations and really
has the ability to play I mean it's it's
an it's very expensive each minute of
recording in a space like that probably
it's incredibly what a lot of pressure
for you guys in that respect as well
right to be there yeah there is if if
you're out of water and you're
uncomfortable it'll be very clear very
quickly yeah but I think that old-school
theater training really helps in
situations like that
yeah I heard Matt saying that earlier
it's it's very true what is it what do
you enjoy about it the most about motion
caps purrs no just a bit obsessed yes in
fact performing about voice acting about
okay oh I just love that you can be
anything that you can imagine you know
when when I was doing more on camera
you're you're stuck and a lot of times
you walk into the room and they've
decided whether or not your cast before
you ever even say a word because your
hair is too dark or your chest is too
small or your nose is too big or
whatever and with voice acting they
don't see you most of the time you
record from home or from your from your
studio and your agency or whatever and
they just listen to the sound and you
know that if you're getting a callback
or if you're getting cast it's because
of your performance
because of what you did which is really
amazing and you own it wholly yes yeah
we get to play every single day when
we're like some of the luckiest people
because it's just our imaginations you
know getting worked if there's anybody
that's like annoyed with work or about
more complaining going to work that they
have no idea what they're talking about
we're working in some of the coolest
universes you know whether it's comics
or you know get game franchises or
anything like that I mean these are
things that we grew up loving as we were
kids and just to be able to be a part of
that and have some sort of art influence
some sort of you know art a core opinion
on a character or a storyline be
implemented and something that's being
produced that's it's just crazy
satisfying for nerds yes and it's funny
I guess the sort of the last one I want
to touch on is kind of what you were
saying earlier which is very interesting
which is that like I'm in the same
situation where when I found it who like
the voice of bender was I'd like realize
a voice of Marcus Fenix is like I don't
really want to know that whereas like in
movies there's this propensity to be
attracted towards the performer and then
watch the movie wholly we grow them
right your guys's work it's almost like
people don't want to know we are dead
like your fine line it's a fine line
that's being made now because a lot of
times things are starting to take
likeness based on voice so you know
we're working on multiple projects that
have actually taken our face and put it
in the game and then you're like huh I
mean that's really cool I love that I
look like a superhero you know and I
could shoot lasers out of my hands at
the same time that that ambiguity is is
a really nice thing in voice acting so
how many roles do you take where they
can see your face and do you want to
back away from it right it's a hard it's
a hard decision
yeah the voice actors that have that
chameleon ability the ability to have
several you know separate voices with
separate personalities is that attached
right you can't see their face you
wouldn't know I mean they're just blue
chip type actors yeah so it's an
interesting thing well we get to the
point where the technology well I guess
we probably are there already where you
can basically be like Andy Serkis right
and just like oh yeah have you know
beaker be Godzilla and be Smeagol and
not they're already one of the greatest
mocap actors out there right now is a
guy named TJ storm that works on a ton
of is that his real name is J Stone the
martial arts Hall of Fame it might even
be
the karate otech he's so cool and he's
so he's huge and he's got these long
braids and he's just the coolest he's
any show Zen you know so Center but he
did the most like you're monk he's a
monk great yeah
it is a nice drunk the vocab forgot
Zilla he did the mocap for Colossus in
the act and Deadpool he was in he was in
knack with us and he played knack so
cool playbook he was giant nag but he
was little neck in his body stance when
he would change and become big neck it's
just so amazing to see the the change in
bodies it's amazing the art of movement
yeah Conor McGregor yeah I should have
been Conor McGregor around 1800 yes
that's the next one you'll be a halfling
yes actually sorry Connor hello Kelly
Thomas Laura thank you so much for
coming on oh hey man today and last note
on this walk video games you guys
playing at the moment know that we can
tell you about wait they were playing or
that were in lame-o play I know I can't
find out why your bin I'm still I am
still deep in fallout world oh cool
although I'm not romancing Matt sorry
Matt I don't even I don't keep any
companions except from a dog me neither
right get that Park don't need to give
the guy a hundred extra pounds gram I
like being solo man bowler man I am in
the division now our free time is almost
nil so I just made it over into
Manhattan which is basically just like
leaving the tutorial so I had a huge
amount of time to hop in with I I go I
hop and turn my brain off so I'm a GTA
guy and a nice Call of Duty 3 or black
ops 3 and you know you playing GTA
online oh yeah that's great
yeah like 79 just run in caused havoc
for two hours he's a troll Brennan he's
a horrible horrible person I got a
fighter jet and you're driving around
town just watch out I love it if there
was ever a game for thought it was GTA
OH